awesome thanks everyone um so i would
love
if you could introduce yourself in in
the chat i've seen brian murphy says hi
hi brian it'd be great to know where you
all are from and
and what you're interested in um i'm
here today and we'll dive into this in a
second to talk about healthy uh data
cultures and what that even means
for some reason i was had enough hubris
to give my talk a subtitle
um it must be somewhat colonial aspect
of my upbringing but the subtitle is
data science as a social discipline
i think for a large portion of the time
uh we have conversations around the
technical aspects of data science
and not the social aspects and cultural
aspects and
it it's time to really start having this
conversation uh
at a larger scale i know a lot of people
who are having this conversation
but to kind of bring this to them to the
forefront
so before we get started i just want to
say a bit about me
my background's in math biology and
physics academic research cell biology
in particular
uh which i did at the max planck
institute for cell biology in dresden
germany
and then at yao university in new haven
connecticut uh
i then as i came to the dark side of
industry but not really the dark side i
started working in uh online
education and moved to new york well
actually prior to that new haven wasn't
quite
the the place for me i lasted five
months there
uh so continued to work at yale while
while living in new york city
for two years um but i did move on
to work in education uh in data science
in evangelism
content development uh and several other
things
at data camp which you may or may not
have
heard of which is an online platform for
data science education and
i also um i hosted a podcast there
called called data framed
which you you may have checked out and
the reason i mentioned that
uh is actually because when i launched
when we launched the podcast data frame
it was the wonderful people at the pi
data nyc meetup who said hey why don't
we have a little
party and a panel and that type of stuff
so we went down to two sigma
uh in in the village um or soho
and had it had what i thought was a
really interesting i was just the
moderator so we had
what i thought was a very interesting
panel uh and then then some drinks um
and all that is is to say that pi data
uh in general but pi data nyc is a place
that i feel
feel at home so it's really wonderful to
be back here today uh in this new
online version of these meet-ups i just
want to thank
uh the the people at sadden uh aaron and
melissa and julia and
everyone else um for putting putting
this on and all the hard work that goes
into this as well
you can see in my photo on on the right
there um i'm wearing a mask
masks for all of course if you are in
new york you may recognize the baseball
cap of cafe grumpy which is one of my
favorite cafes in the city and i was
very sad to see that uh their
soho location recently closed down um
recently i've i've moved uh
companies uh i'm now working at coiled
where
what we do is uh we're building products
uh that bring the power of scalable data
science and machine learning to you
such as single click hosted clusters on
the cloud that allow you
to seamlessly move your software
environments and data between your local
computation and cloud-based computation
essentially one way of framing what we
want to do
is to take the bloody devops out of data
science so you can get back to your real
job as a data scientist
i said this to a few of you in the
breakout sessions you know if you're a
data scientist who loves
you know kubernetes and docker
containers and wrangling all of that
more power to you um but a lot of data
scientists just want to get their
analyses
up and running and their modeling up and
running there's a huge barrier to entry
there
when building large models or working
with large data sets uh
so i joined coyle several months ago
matt rocklin who is a core contributor
and co-maintainer of
of darsk started the company essentially
because there were so many
uh requests for this type of
infrastructure
and tooling around dusk and pi data in
in general
so i where i mean we've just started the
company so i i wear several hats there
um from evangelism to marketing pivoting
currently to do a bunch of stuff
in product which is really exciting um
and
you can find me uh at hugo bound at most
places
um twitter and and so forth okay so
that's really enough uh about me um i'm
here today to talk about healthy
uh data cultures um and i'm gonna start
talking about what's unhealthy currently
and something that
we could refer to as data science
leakage um then i wanna talk about how
we got here and even thinking about like
wait
where are we after like quote unquote 10
years of data science or whatever it's
been
um then think about establishing and
building
healthy healthy data cultures and then a
brief case study
uh in distributed compute and the
problems around tooling and distributing
compute and what we're trying to solve
at coiled as well okay so i asked a
question a poll on twitter recently
how much of your organization's data
work is actually used in decision making
and those decisions could be automated
so
if you work at twitter uh and you do
data work that result
that results in servicing or automatedly
servicing content i'd like that to be
included um
the options were 0 to 25 26 to 50
51 to 75 and 76 to 100 so i just want
you to take a second
to think about um and i actually have a
poll question for you later so that's
why i'm not polling you now
um but i'd like you to take a second to
to think about this
um and also note that this may uh vary
across industry if any of you feels like
poppy in the chat
a number you know the percentage of your
organization's data work
that's used in decision making um you
can
you know you could count it in human
hours for example feel free to do so i
don't want to put anyone on the spot
though
um now the result i was
i wasn't surprised i was maybe a bit
shocked and a bit saddened
but i definitely wasn't surprised and it
shows how much work we have to do
um so over 50 the main takeaway
i i want to state is that over 50 of
people
said less than 25 of their
organization's data work is
actually used in decision making okay
now i appreciate
uh there are all types of problems and
biases associated with these these types
of polls
um you know including selection bias all
types of stuff
um so i want this to be taken with a
grain of salt having said that
the reason i ask this is because in my
job and you know over the past five
years i spent a lot of time speaking
with
with with data scientists and people in
the data
the data sphere um and
this is an ongoing trend that i'm
actually i feel
uh that we're seeing perhaps
a devaluation in how people consider the
roi
on non-automated data science in
particular and we'll we'll get to this
in a second okay um but i think what's
very important to recognize
is from this at least a lot of data
scientists
seem to feel that their work uh is
entering a vacuum that is not actually
being used
uh for what we would like it to be to be
used for
okay um a few a few things here
a few replies um mikhail popov who it's
it's key to recognize that mikhail is a
senior data scientist and product
analytics at the wikimedia foundation
which includes such products as
wikipedia his response was feel like
he feels like i don't know should be an
option i think which is
which is very telling on top of that and
this talk isn't just going to be based
around tweets okay
i'm not that brilliant um but it's good
to have aspirations
tanya kashurali who is a founder of tcp
analytics um
uh a boston area based uh consulting
data consulting group who works across a
lot of different uh
industries um and someone who i who i
follow
um because i find her so uh
revelatory with respect to kind of what
happens in the field in data science
she responded she'd argue that no one
even knows how to measure the impact of
data science or analytics well
at all i would say we do in in tech i
think
and when it's automated um so that's
something we'll
we'll come back to uh the other thing
that she made clear
is that it depends on the type of
organization uh and so
if we go back to this poll if we
segmented this
via you know tech um finance
uh healthcare consulting retail would
see vastly
vastly different different results and
that that's a very interesting question
to ask
even if i do say so myself i mean it was
tenuous question um
so why are we seeing all this data
leakage um or why are we seeing this
perception
of data leakage and i'd love to know in
the chat if this resonates with your
experience working in in data
at all so how do we get here that was
the initial title of this section
but then i was like wait where even are
we i don't even know
where we are um in terms of you know is
this injury industry just
breaking into like all different groups
of specialization is data science on the
out because
it's obvious that you know we're going
to need far more data engineers and data
scientists and data analysts
etc are we entering an era of you know
like huge investment in bi tools i mean
the the sales force and
well yeah the acquisitions of looker and
tableau
in in the past couple of years um and
the amount of
people investing in in bi tools is is
mind-boggling as well
so let's we can even ask like where are
we
so i i want to just start with
kind of where we started and i i know i
know that when people
like data science started in like 2010
or and then other people like
actually i was doing data science in
like the 1750s or whatever
um i totally get that and and i don't
actually mean that facetiously
data science has a huge long history and
i appreciate it wasn't called
i was doing data science before data
science was even a thing great
thank you for that feedback um but if we
want to look
at the origin of a data science
marketplace
we do want to look back to around a
decade ago and what i mean by that is a
time where
uh data science was coined as a term
people bought in
to this reality and or delusion of data
science being something that would
deliver
extreme value to a lot of different uh
industries
we want to look back to 2010 to 2012
right
um and the origins of a marketplace
where there's supply of people
becoming and calling themselves fully
fledged data scientists and then demand
on a business side
that essentially uh started in tech and
i would say one of the first
maybe one of the first big proofs of
principle of data science in tech
um the first really famous one with a a
b
test circa 2000 of google with the
number of search results where they're
like
we're going to do a b test and show you
know 10 results to some people 15 to 20
and and then optimize for
click-through rate or whatever it was
that test totally failed for
infrastructure reasons um but i do think
looking at the last 10 years
is going to be incredibly telling um to
how we got into a situation where data
science
in some industries doesn't see and a lot
of workplaces doesn't seem to be
delivering the value
we thought it would okay um so i think
it's instructive to ask the question
where is data science uh
in the gartner hype cycle um and i'll
get you to answer that question in the
poll
in a second but for those unfamiliar
with the gartner hype cycle
um it's a model of technological
innovation and expectations
with respect to different uh
technologies uh
so we have time on the x-axis
expectations on the y-axis
with any technology we have an
innovation trigger and people like okay
this is something so that's what i'm
thinking around 2010 2012.
um the innovation trigger may even be a
term of course it's based around uh
you know the amount of data available uh
the amount of compute available
uh the sophistication of algorithms
the these these types of things i mean
those are actually the main three
um then uh as expectations go up and
maybe some values delivered but
maybe not as much as you'd think we
reached the peak of inflated
expectations where people like
wait a second we're expecting all this
stuff and you know blurg
um and people flip out a bit they're
like whatever uh we get into the trough
of disillusionment and only after this
do we start seeing the slope of
enlightenment
uh where we see actual value really
delivered uh and then the plateau of
productivity
um so uh melissa um
mel very generously i did a poll
question um so if you click next to the
chat on polls
uh i want you to tell me where you think
data science is in the gartner hype
cycle
are we at the innovation trigger the
peak of inflated expectations the trough
of disillusionment or the slope the
slope of enlightenment or the product of
the plateau of productivity so let's
just take 30 seconds to
answer that all right so here's what
we've got well
uh number one is the slope of
enlightenment so people actually tend to
agree with me that's around 29
of everybody there it's it's more of a
plurality i mean it's very close there's
26 percent
of people saying it's the peak of
inflated expectations
and we've got a good chunk 23 percent in
the trough of disillusionment
amazing amazing um i find that very
very telling that we get some sort of
bimodal
activity um and i would one thing if we
had more time i'd interrogate what
industries you're all thinking about
as well and where you work and what your
own biases are
um because you could argue that in tech
we're definitively in the slope of
enlightenment
um whereas in you know if
uh healthcare for example we could be at
the peak of
there there are arguments for that that
i've heard heard before okay
so let's i'm not going to answer this
question but by the way but i'll kind of
reason
about it in in a few ways okay um so
before i answer where is data science in
in the hype cycle
let's think about where is big data in
the hype cycle and um
i'm using this is google trends i'm
using
as a proxy for expectations uh google
trends so search results uh sorry search
queries right
um so we see over time that uh
big data you know it became very very in
vogue
you know around here then around 2014 it
started to drop off
okay so if we accept the gartner hype
cycle
as a model for technological innovation
with respect to big data here and we
accept uh uh google trends as a proxy
for societal expectations so we're
making a whole bunch of assumptions
there right um
then it may look as though we're kind of
mentally entering
um the uh
i'm sorry um the
trough of disillusionment for for big
data okay um
even if we don't accept the gartner hype
cycle we can say that societal
expectations or people's interest has
has gone down right and whether that has
to do with value creation or not i
i think we could argue strongly that
that it does or lack of value creation
for big data
in a lot of ways um having said that now
let's just compare this to
uh data science over time okay
so check this out yeah around 2010 2012
people started searching it
okay um and we saw it go up and up and
up and up
and up and you know you take your
rolling averages whatever and it
seems like we maybe haven't even hit
the peak of inflated expectations yet
well we can't definitively see a peak
there may be some sort of
plateauing here so we may be reaching
some sort of peak uh
around here um and that's that's what i
would argue that that we're at we're
around the peak of inflated expectations
as i've made very clear um in tech i i
don't think we are
um i i think we got it pretty spot on
um almost initially uh there and
actually data science
a modern data science um in terms of its
approach tools
techniques emerged in in tech um
so the question is if if we are around
this peak of inflated expectations
what does the trough of disillusionment
look like and and what's happening there
and what will happen there
and i'll actually argue i think that a
lot of the challenges
um a lot of a lot of people feeling like
data science isn't valued or it isn't
uh involved in the decision-making
process actually is part of what this
trough of dissolution
will will look like uh and in particular
we need to decouple the conversation
between automated data science work
uh and decision science okay a lot of
the wins
of data are in the automated setting and
not in the decision science setting
um and this is a cultural challenge okay
so this is kind of what i've written
here um where have we seen the biggest
wins for data science in tech and in
automated decision making
what else i really welcome your
responses in the chat here
uh but i would argue that it's not in
informing the decision function
right um so the interfaces to figure out
this is courtesy of renee t uh who i
would very much encourage you to follow
she's a data scientist um and she had a
wonderful podcast and has lots of great
resources
called becoming a data scientist um
but she factored the decision-making
process which is usually going through a
business question from a business
question to a business answer
through specifically through uh
factoring the business question into a
data question
and then factoring the data answer into
a business answer and there's these
interfaces that we're incredibly
interested in uh
and what you see a lot of the time are
things like type three errors right
where you get the correct answer the
correct data answer
but to the wrong business question
because this interface uh between
data and business hasn't actually worked
uh correctly which is one of the reasons
why automated
data work has been successful because
when it automated
automates it if you have a way of
measuring it immediately
you can go in and then see exactly where
it's working
and where it is in in terms of the data
pipeline
um it is for this reason that mckinsey
for example and this is mckinsey did
this two years ago but it's still
catching on
um really pushed for a new role called a
data translator or an analytics
translator
and this is the person that sits
essentially between the data function
sorry the decision function and the data
function who can speak both those
languages
and this really speaks to a cultural
cultural concern
uh so i'm aware we're running up against
time i wonder if we um
because we started slightly late aaron
if you're okay with me going for another
five to ten minutes
yeah yeah yeah we started like three
four minutes late so
okay perfect um so i just i've called
this talk healthy data cultures and
because it's a relatively short talk i
can't really go in into the weeds um but
i want to just give a few rules of thumb
that i've noticed from my conversations
with everyone uh the work that i've done
in data strategy and data strategy
consulting as well
and also the work i've done in in trying
um some of the time successfully to
figure out a data camp in particular how
uh
organizations can spread data literacy
and data fluency skills throughout their
organizations right uh and this is once
again a deeply cultural concern
so the key moving parts of a healthy
data culture
and there are definitely more but i
think you can boil most of it down to
five
really key things uh you need firstly a
vision
you need an analytics and data vision
but it has to be aligned it can't exist
in its own vacuum
it has to be aligned with company
strategy with company vision mission
company goals and company strategy okay
uh also speaking to this
you need strong top-down support uh you
ideally
have a ceo who's deeply invested in
building up a data culture and
a data strategy um along with like
satellite roles
at sea level um you also want to
demonstrate
uh immediate value it doesn't need to be
a huge amount of value but immediate
value from early use cases in the first
month or two
even not necessarily going for ai
moonshots
but showing that for example basic
online experimentation
can increase conversion uh which drives
revenue you know
small things like this which actually
have big impact the unsexy things
uh and the small things which may result
in in big impact that you can get done
in a couple of months
uh in so when you've got c-level support
then going back and saying hey look what
we've done
uh in in the past two to three months
the next thing you really need and this
is something that we're thinking about a
lot of coiled in addition to all of
these other things
is having data foundations having struck
infrastructure and tools set up
so that people can do their work as
simply as possible
uh and then you want to make it stick
and this is
a deeply cultural part you want to
redesign processes
in terms of how humans interact even in
terms of how data results are presented
you send round dashboards or do you
actually have
daily stand-ups or do you have meetings
where the data scientist is in the room
with a decision maker
uh giving a five-minute five-minute
presentation um
other ways to make it stick cultural are
getting people to ask the right
questions
so i actually recently i've been
chatting with um
skipper siebold so you may know skipper
he was formerly at civis
uh he's now director of advanced
analytics at
hca healthcare um he built stats models
if any of you have used that in in
pi data in python land um i actually had
him on
my podcast some time ago the episode was
called
uh the credibility crisis in in data
science so we discussed a lot of these
these types of things and he said
something he tries to do is to get our
decision makers and executives
to um actually pose their questions as
testable hypotheses
and making that a part of the culture
okay so these are ways to think about
making it stick culturally angelique
angela busser who is the head of data
science and machine learning at irobot
throws data parties where everyone get
gets around they order some pizza or
like i don't whatever keto thing what
we're all doing these days
um and and gets everyone
diving into the databases and sees
what's happening there okay um
so a couple of relevant resources for
these types of things about really what
needs to be in place for um
for data cultures to be developed uh a
conversation i had with tarasgarishni
uh about his work at mckinsey um in in
data science and he was head of start
he's actually i head of data science now
at cvs is my understanding
and then the ai transformation playbook
uh which andrewing
uh developed um so i'm gonna
wrap up in in a few minutes i do want to
say
uh we did a uh we published a white
paper which is really for business
leaders
we did this at datacamp was one of the
last things i did there the bitly links
there
um one thing we asked uh this was you
know we
did a survey of you know 250 uh
people in different organizations across
uh different
verticals um and ask them to what extent
their company
has taken the following actions all the
ones i've just enumerated
and you can see that the ones with
mature data fluency or data literacy
competencies um far excelled you know 44
of them had created a vision for
analytics aligned with strategy whereas
only six percent
of those within mature um data
competencies had uh
and so on and i could list all the data
there but you can see the start the
start difference
there okay so
one of the things i talked about was
infrastructure and data foundations
and tooling right uh and at coiled
uh as i mentioned at the start where
we're building tools
um to bring the power of scalable data
science and machine learning
to you so for example single click click
hosted clusters on on the cloud we're
also doing uh
a bunch of consulting support and
training which speaks to other cultural
aspects
um but i am actually deeply interested
in how
products how commercial products can
help us solve for
organizational cultural challenges uh
and to drill a bit deeper into this
uh brian granger once once said to me on
so brian granger's co-leader project
jupiter
among many other many other things he he
said to me on
on on the podcast um hugo we're now
entering
an era where large complex organizations
need to scale interactive compute
uh with data to their entire
organization in a manner that is
collaborative
secure and human centered another thing
brian said
uh in um he said we're entering a phase
transition and i like this
formulation from from from a physicist
we're entering a phase transition
where previously uh had a lot of
individual
open source users within them um to
uh a stage in which organizations are
now adopting
open source themselves institutionally
and how does this
change what we need to do with the open
source and one thesis of mine is that
the open source
uh ecosystem let's talk about pi data
has
been incredible at uh allowing
individual working scientists data
analysts and data scientists and
research scientists
to answer science science questions okay
it's done an incredible job at that
what it hasn't done there are some
collaborative tools in the open source
but it hasn't solved
the large scale in institutional
questions and nor should it
perhaps this is where the enterprise
does need to come in and companies such
as coiled arise out of this need
uh to help uh the open source meet the
needs of the enterprise and help the
enterprise
leverage the power of open source so one
way to think about it is
um any organization or institution we
can think of as a network right
and open source really solves for the
nodes but it may not solve for the edges
so that's something we're really
exploring
uh at coil okay so to that end
uh i'll wrap up by telling you a few
other things we're doing
um there was a promise that big data
plus
data science team equals up and to the
right
profit right so there's actually a lot
more to it as i'm sure you'll appreciate
uh if you want to do it safely which you
definitely definitely do
and by safely what i really mean is
minimizing risk for the company
okay so the problem is that all of this
big data stuff and big models comes with
big headaches uh and matt
and i matt rocklin uh my ceo and i uh
wrote a series of articles about these
challenges on medium because of the
quirks of medium there's only one
possible author here but if you check
out
coiled medium and the unbearable
challenges of data science at scale
you'll see a bunch of what i'm about to
about to mention um
but there are big headaches for data
scientists right
so software are the questions do my
machines and cluster all have the same
software can i upgrade packages easily i
mean if you're using data bricks that's
going to be actually incredibly
incredibly tough uh and you know we
argue that these all-in-one platforms
don't serve like the nimble and agile
needs of modern data scientists to
to use like the the new release of
tensorflow or whatever it may be
uh another question uh resource sharing
can i share these same machines with my
team
there are data access questions so all
of these
once trying to work with big data on a
cluster or build big models on a cluster
you start running up against all these
problems and this is something we're
solving for at coiled so you can see
screenshots here of someone interacting
with a giant cluster you can see this
great
pew pew plot and it's got its pew pew
pew pew pew because
uh when it's in motion you see uh the
schedule i talked to
all the workers and you can see so this
is someone interacting with the cluster
from their local jupiter lab
uh and you can see here uh someone
working with a particular con
condor environment which we allow them
to move simply between their local
workstation
and the cloud other organizational
challenges are for team leads
and management uh so cost avoidance
tracking and optimizing
uh where are we spending money on the
cluster what's being used what isn't um
also enabling collaboration how do we
replicate the experience of our top
performers
so something we're thinking uh about um
and and building is advanced telemetry
for the team leads as to what's
happening in in their organization
uh in order to enable collaboration
avoid costs and track and optimize
the final and maybe this should be the
zero if we're zero indexing
uh persona we really need to think about
is i.t they require predictability
uh security and observability i'd love
to go into this a bit more but in the
interests of time
i won't um and so i mean we need
products
uh that allow uh it needs to be met
while uh data scientists needs and team
leads are met
as well uh to enable large-scale
institutional scalable
data science okay um so
without uh i think that's that's a great
place to end i'd i'd love for you to
come and come and play with us
um we've got a free beta product that
you can take for a test drive if you
want to get some scalable
uh uh clusters running up immediately at
beta.coil.io
you can check out our jobs at coil.io
jobs
follow us on twitter or something i
really i'm enjoying at the moment we
have weekly live streams on our youtube
channel so you can hit hit subscribe
there
and actually in just under 24 hours uh
where we are we're having deepak sherian
who
he's a physical oceanographer i've got
to get this right at the national center
for atmospheric research
talking about how he leverages dark and
x-ray uh
to uh model um the oceans
right so so there you go um so i'd love
for you all to get involved and feel
free to ping me uh
at any point um i had some
aside for questions we may not have time
for questions uh i'll pass off to aaron
cool well thank you so much hugo that
was a great talk thank you for that
um and then time for questions now um
but
if you want to talk to hugo you can you
know ask a question in the chat or hugo
do you mind putting like your email your
twitter handle in the chat so people
know how to
to contact you later absolutely i think
um
twitter's probably the best you can try
email but
but email at the moment is yeah you can
put your twitter handle on there too
yup that's cool okay click on you can
find me on linkedin as well but i'm
probably
more available on twitter um i just want
to say thank you everyone again for
joining
uh thanks aaron and mel for setting this
up and thanks trisha for
looking forward to your talk as well
great thank you hugo